[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interwiew avec cette
semaine le grand plaisir de recevoir
fanny ardant bonjour fanny ardant merci
de jeu de nous avoir rejoints sur sur ce
plateau je rappelle que nous sommes dans
deux studios séparer alors c'est pas
très confortable pour la conversation
vous êtes dans le centre de paris
et moi je suis ici dans les studios de
boulogne je dis ça pour indiquer que
nous respectons les conditions
sanitaires
je dis ça aussi pour certain nombre de
mes amis qui apprenant que je vous
rencontre est et qui sont très cinéphile
était très jaloux de ce privilège
alors je vous remercie et comment vous
vivez cette période d'isolement en fait
non parce que finalement je le premier
est la première enfermement j'en ai
profité pour lire et pour
re jouer du piano et puis là j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir tourner dans les films
où il était permis de tourner donc je ne
me suis pas sentie tant que ça isolé
j'ai fait mon métier vous n'avez jamais
je n'ai pas pu jouer au théâtre
mais vous avez réussi à faire votre
métier c'est à dire qu'il ya détruit le
tournage n'ont pas été ont repris
pendant le déconfinement et se sont
arrêtés depuis là depuis un mois non non
non moi depuis j'ai commencé à tourner
en septembre et je suis encore en
tournage
enfin parce que les gens respectent
exactement les masquer et tout donc on
continue à tourner avec les mesures de
précaution on va parler de cette
actualité qui nous oblige bien sûr à
prendre toutes ses précautions
on va parler évidemment du cinéma de
votre actualité à vous et puis on va
parler aussi de la russie parce que vous
êtes une amoureuse de la russie de la
littérature de la culture de ce pays des
gens de russie qui vous le rendent bien
parce que vous êtes très célèbre et très
connu aussi en russie
on commence par le métier si vous le
voulez bien et votre actualité sauf
erreur de ma part le dernier film qui
soit sorti en salles mais dans des
conditions compliquées puisque on était
en pleine crise c'est le film de maïwenn
adn certains ont réussit un film qui
était d'ailleurs sélectionnés pour aller
à cannes qui s'est retrouvé à deauville
en septembre mais dont la sortie en
salle prévue pour le 29 octobre à un peu
avortée
c'est très frustrant pour l'équipe d'un
film pour une réalisation de ne pas
sortir en salles comme il devrait sortir
oui c'est comme une bouteille qui n'est
lancée à la mer qui n'est jamais arrivé
sur la plage en même temps moi par
exemple si quelqu'un qui ne regarde pas
les films que je tourne donc il reste
dans mon imaginaire et que je pense que
un film à une longue vie contrairement à
la télévision un film voyage
peut-être que
quand cet enfermement rafini il ira dans
d'autres pays
donc il ya quelque chose je pense je
pense à maïwenn et je pense que ça a dû
être un un chagrin parce qu'en effet
c'est comme si on était sur un starting
blocks qu'on est prêt à offrir quelque
chose et qui n'arrive jamais oui mais
vous êtes associé au film on peut pas on
peut pas s'empêcher de penser que vous
je veux pas dire que vous soyez coauteur
mais vous êtes associé au film nous
apporter beaucoup plus que que votre
image de la porter autre chose on ne
sait pas ce qu'on apporte ce que c'est
dans chacun savait que celui le
spectateur de la salle obscure c'est lui
le dernier metteur en scène c'est celui
qui choisit qu'est-ce qui va regarder
qu'est-ce qui va l'émouvoir qu'est-ce
qui va là avec quoi il va se sentir
proche ou pas c'est une histoire
ben le film de maïwenn sur l'histoire
familiale sur l'adn sur la recherche de
ses origines
est ce que ça veut dire que vous êtes
très sensibles à ça ce que vous êtes
resté fidèle vous à vos origines à la
fois géographique familia geographic ccc
le sait que c'est quoi c'est le limousin
c'est mais vous avez beaucoup voyagé
oui et moi curieusement je ne ferai
jamais de recherches adn
moi j'aime l'idée de l'ambiguïté du
mystère de l'imagination
je ne veux pas qu'on vienne me prouver a
+ b + c que je viens de ça donc j'aime
l'idée que voilà je peux m'imaginer ma
vie mais que en effet moi je suis
d'origine
je suis né à saumur mes parents mon père
était du limousin mal a été de
fontainebleau
donc voyez il ya c'est très le
territoire français mais après qu'est ce
qu'on sait des parents des grands
parents
peut-être qu'on célébrait licence j'aime
l'idée du mystère et j'ai toujours fait
confiance aux aux inconnus alors
pourquoi êtes vous allé dans le dans le
cinéma dans le théâtre
j'ai commencé par le théâtre parce que
je trouvais que
ce qui était beau le verbe beau éclater
un fort devait devaient se partager
on devait monter sur scène pour partager
ce qui était beau comme l'offrir et puis
comme ça de de pièce en pièce je suis
arrivé au monde du cinéma mais comme par
hasard parce que la première qui m'est
donné une chance était nina companeez
dans 1 dans une série à l'époque on
disait pas les séries ont dealé des
feuilletons les dames de la côte est
après j'ai fait la femme d'à côté de
françois truffaut et puis voilà il a été
comme voilà les mais j'ai jamais oublier
le théâtre j'ai toujours continué à
jouer au théâtre
vous avez joué au théâtre il n'y a pas
très longtemps un en 2018 2019 encore
jamais complètement abandonné le théâtre
i je pense toujours que les théâtres
pour un acteur c'est son allié je pense
toujours que le théâtre purifie le sang
on est tout seul sur scène ou avec des
acteurs mais on est sans filet c'est
comme si on descendait dans la fosse aux
lions donc je pense j'avais été très
impressionné par les grands acteurs
anglais comme sean connery qui après
avoir joué
james bond retourner à stratfor sur
evene pour jouer shakespeare
je pense que théâtre nourris celui qui
le fait alors si on revient au cinéma
avec on regarde votre filmographie est
assez exceptionnel vous avez tourné à
peu près avec les plus grands
réalisateurs les plus grands metteurs en
scène français mais aussi beaucoup
d'étrangers on est quand même frappé de
cette carrière est la question que je
voulais vous vous posez c'est est
d'abord comment vous vous imaginiez là
l'avenir de ce cinéma là lorsque vous
voyez aujourd'hui le développement d'une
industrie
il s'est accaparé netflix s'est accaparé
des des équipes industrielles pour
fabriquer des scénarios alors que vous
vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
d'auteur dans le cinéma de créateurs
initiateur je crois que le cinéma c'est
comme la peinture c'est comme le la
littérature ça reste un art
vous savez malraux disait l'ambiguïté du
cinéma c'est que c'est un art et une
industrie peut-être que maintenant c'est
l'industrie qui gagne mais du coup
peut-être que ce qui va rester c'est que
les films qui seront de plus en plus
fait pour le cinéma et pas sur les
grands réseaux resteront des objets
artistiques
il y aura comme une petite république
souterraine des films qui reste des
films de cinéma
peut-être qu'il ya moi d'industrie
cinématographique mais peut-être que
c'est mieux que tout d'un coup l'objet
va rester dans sa pureté initial et
qu'on n'oubliera de toujours penser au
profit au retour en quoi on a gagné de
l'argent ou pas c'est pour ça que c'est
toujours ambigu le cinéma parce que ça
coûte cher et en même temps il ne
faudrait pas penser à faire à plaire aux
spectateurs
il faut l'offrir comme quelque chose que
soi-même dans lequel on croit et pas
cherché à plaire aux spectateurs
ce n'est que dans cette forme là que le
cinéma continuera à vivre
s'il rentre dans la formation d'un objet
qui doit être vendue comme les boîtes de
camembert ou comme les chaussures ou les
tomates alors le cinéma deviendra
quelque chose comme ça à vendre à vendre
mais maintenant il ya aussi une
différence de relation au cinéma de la
part du spectateur
il est tout seul face à son film dans
une salle noire alors que sur netflix
il aida il est face à son poste de
télévision ou à sa tablette
c'est quand même différent il ya d'un
côté un média chaud un média froid qu
homme dit
mc luhan autrefois c'était godard qui
disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma on lève
les yeux
tout est dit donc voila et ont rejoint
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure à
savoir que vous ne vous n'alliez pas
voir vos films mais mais que les films
vivait tout seul il s'était des longues
c'est l'heure il se vendait très
longtemps c'est ça oui parce que tout
d'un coup on peut tourner un film peut
arriver dans dans un an dans l'autre
côté de l'atlantique et du pacifique
voilà on ne sait rien de la vie des
films et peut-être qu'un film quelqu'un
va le voir dix ans après qu'on l'ait
tournai est comme moi j'ai pu découvrir
des films qui est qui avait été tourné
il ya très longtemps
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que c'est
comme la peinture ou comme la musique ou
comme la littérature peu importe qu'on
ait lu ou qu'on ait vu un film au moment
de sa sortie
ça reste un objet qui précieux que un
jour quelqu'un vous dit a jamais vu ça
tatata pas regarder ça tu connais pas
tel metteur en scène et là un monde
entier s'ouvre à vous et c'est magique
alors vous avez eu non plus la chance
mais c'est pas la chance et votre talent
qui a fait ça est votre votre passion de
tournai énormément mais vous continuez
de tourner encore énormément
actuellement 1
comment choisissez vous parce que vous
devez déborder de d'offres de
propositions comment choisissez-vous un
film un projet un scénario un
réalisateur alors déjà on pourrait dire
que avant de choisir on est choisi et
moi je pense que quand je lis un
scénario que heureusement je dis souvent
que je ne suis pas une actrice
professionnelle parce que je ne peux
jouer que les rôles que j'aime j'ai pas
dis que j'ai besoin que les autres
aiment mon rôle je peux jouer le rôle
d'un monstre je peux jouer le rôle d'un
l'ennemi public numéro un
mais moi quand je joue devant le
scénario j'ai besoin d'aimer absolument
mon personnage parce que je ne sinon j'y
arriverai pas à le jouer si je n'aime
pas si je la trouve
que tout va que j'arrive pas elle n'est
pas obligée de me ressembler aux non
plus mais donc dans voilà moi j'ai
besoin de faire partie d'une histoire
dans lequel ce que je vais défendre le
rôle que je vais les se défend je vais
l'aimer
la personnalité du réalisateur est quand
même au coeur de l'équation non pas tant
que ça finalement
parce que on ne connaît quelqu'un que
quand on travaille avec lui un plateau
révèle le metteur en scène et les
acteurs
ça sert à rien de se connaître avant
parce que c'est comme mondain
on raconte puisque le travail de sur
scène ou sur un plateau avec l'urgence
avec la passion avec le la fébrilité
fait que voilà tout le monde en laissant
mars classement vous vous avez quoi en
fabrication aujourd'hui là où je viens
justement de finir de tourner un film de
carine tardieu avec melvil poupaud
différences leurs écailles cécile de
france et là je suis en train de faire
un rôle cours dans un film de clovis
cordina de clovis cornillac qui
s'appelle les couleurs de l' incendie et
donc de films qui se sont succédé oui
mais dont j'aimais beaucoup les rôles
que l'on verra à la rentrée lorsque le
cobp idra aura disparu s'il disparaît
fanny ardant je ne voudrais pas on va
reprendre sa dent en quelques minutes on
fait simplement une petite pause
[Musique]
on se retrouve sur le plateau de la
grande interview avec fanny ardant
on a beaucoup parlé cinéma évidemment on
a beaucoup parlé de deux de vos projets
je voudrais avoir votre sentiment sur la
façon dont le cinéma est quand même en
train d'évoluer dans le monde
aujourd'hui avec des îlots qui reste
assez prospère intellectuellement je
parle de l'île aux français par exemple
qui est une exception culturelle
française
mais je parle aussi des séries est ce
que cette mutation là va se poursuivre
est-ce qu'elle va changer le métier que
vous faites est celui de comédien ou
d'acteurs non je crois pas que le fait
d'être acteur c'est c'est comme si tout
d'un coup on est acteur dès qu'on se
l'est avec on raconte une histoire
ça peut être devant un rideau noir ou
devant un rideau rouge ça peut être avec
une grande sophistication ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
donc je pense que ça depuis eschyle
c'est toujours la même chose
c'est plutôt moi je me dis toujours que
souvent ma demande et la 10e
quelle est la différence entre de jouer
au théâtre ou de jouer au cinéma et je
disais pour moi il n'y a aucune
différence
la différence et c'est celui c'est le
spectateur du théâtre où le spectateur
du cinéma et maintenant le spectateur de
la télévision vous n'êtes pas le même
quand vous à rentrer dans la salle
obscure d'un théâtre que vous attendez
qui a après il ya les applaudissements
qu'il ya tout ça le rideau qui se lève
le fait que ça dure une heure et demie
et deux heures dans un lieu fermé le
cinéma aux syllabes sécurité et que si
vous êtes chez vous donc finalement
c'est en tant que spectateur qu'on est
différent mais celui qui fabrique
l'objet il est le même
alors on me dit que sur netflix il ya
des moyens donc quelquefois c'est une
chance peut-être de faire parvenir au
monde une histoire qui aurait très peu
de chances d'être produite au cinéma
parce qu on se dirait mais pour quel
genre de public
je sais que toi je pense qu'il ya
toujours de la place pour tout le monde
moi j'ai peut-être 6
une incurable positive c'est que il ya
de la place pour tout le monde que je
n'aime pas les monopoles que je n'aime
pas la pensée unique que je n'aime pas
que tout le monde fasse pareil il y aura
toujours des gens qui vont dans des
clubs de jazz alors qu'il y allait y
aller disent qu'ils allaient céder qui à
la radio il ya toujours ceux qui ont
envie de partager dans la salle obscure
une grande émotion
donc je pense que chacun ira vers ce qui
lui lui ressemble le plus je pense que
moi j'ai toujours aimé les films marty
même moi qui suis une anti américaines
primaire et j'ai aimé souvent tout le
1er grande américain a trouvé très
intéressant alors qu'on vous dit dès les
séries
je pense que par exemple c'est bien pour
pouvoir mettre en scène des stendhal des
tolstoï des balzac des tous les grands
romans du xixème siècle avec des moyens
avec des scénaristes
donc je cracherais pas dessus non vous
ne passe que je brosse nous ne
refuserait pas une série 1
on vous offrira de faire une série un
jour c'est un jeu je voulais vous
demander si vous vous sentiez actrice ou
comédienne la question se pose parce que
des gens comme alain delon ou jean gabin
que j'avais rencontré autrefois ils
s'étaient des acteurs et il refusait
d'être des équipes se sentait pas
comédien oui vous sentez là je devrais
dire plus facilement une actrice
oui j'aime beaucoup le mot d'actrice
vaya acte agir
j'aime assez près alors le métier il est
aussi traversé par des par des
mouvements sociaux logique vous avez été
très critique par exemple vous même et
ça a été très remarquée à l'encontre du
mouvement mis tout gêné au cinéma et qui
a donné qui a libéré la parole des
femmes un peu au cinéma pour dénoncer
des comportements sexistes qui pouvait y
avoir dans cette industrie ou sur le
plateau on pense notamment à la dernière
cérémonie des césar au cours de laquelle
vous aviez reçu le césar de croix de
meilleur deuxième rôle pour le film de
nicolas bedos vous aviez pris la défense
en de polanski 1
et ça alors ça c'était clivant
curieusement moi j'ai dit tout ce que
j'avais à dire c'est que quand j'aime
quelqu'un je vais défunt jusque jusqu'au
bout je ne rentre pas dans le dans le
jugement
j'ai beaucoup de mal d'ailleurs à juger
j'aime les je considère toujours que
l'être humain est contradictoire avec
des parts d'ombré de lumière mais qui
fait non je n'aime pas le jugement
feuillard dont on disait en commençant
l'émission tout le monde sait que vous
êtes amoureuse de la russie ça remonte à
quand cet amour delà de la russie de la
culture rue de la littérature russe
parce que vous c'est pas vos origines
n'est pas à bord at-il on en a parlé
tout à l'heure
non je pense que j'ai commencé très
jeune j'ai connu de la russie j'ai connu
la russie a traversé en son art
j'habitais monaco j'allais à l'opéra et
j'ai commencé à voir tous les grands
opéras lé prince igor boris goudounov la
khovantchina et puis je j'ai lu très
jeunes très tôt tous les grands romans
russes des étés entier après j'ai alors
que j'avais du mal avec la poésie
française
j'ai toujours été tout de suite dans la
poésie russe
vous trouvez toujours qu'il y avait dans
la poésie dépôt est riche comme une
urgence comme une question de vie ou de
mort donc je les connaissais par coeur
aussi à travers leur peinture la musique
la littérature la poésie
donc on me disait toujours tu connais la
russie d'une façon romanesque mais
finalement moi je me disais l'art d'un
pays c'est son essence c'est comme une
sorte de raccourci comme les poètes les
grands créateurs sont des extra lucide
il arrive à trouver
l'essence même d'un peuple donc au fond
quand je suis arrivé en russie
je connaissais le meilleur de la russie
je connaissais ce qui profondément il
était mais pas d'une façon rationnelle
un peu comme vous savez les chiens qui
rentre dans la forêt et qui ont ils tout
les effluves de la forêt et petit à
petit comme j'y suis allée toujours pour
des raisons professionnelles
moi c'est très rare que je voyage pour
le tourisme j'ai connu les russes j'ai
commencé par connaître les journalistes
russes c'était avant le la chute du mur
de berlin
donc il était intense je sentais qu'il
cherchait à rentrer dans les choses
essentielles et pas les ragots qui les
trucs insupportable ou sont sans fiche
de ça puis après j'ai commencé à
travailler
j'ai été invité pour jouer au théâtre
puis j'avais des amis et à chaque fois
que je revenais je retrouvais les mêmes
amis donc il y avait quelque chose où je
me suis beaucoup passionné pour
l'histoire de la russie surtout
l'histoire du 20e siècle cette histoire
tragique
c'est absolument irrationnel mon amour
de la russie c'est en faire beaucoup
d'amour sont irrationnels c'était un peu
la définition vous avez fait un film en
2016 le divan de staline que vous avez
réalisé ça mais c'est pas sûr la risée
pas sur la russie romantique c'est pas
là-dessus re la russie lyrics et pas sur
la russie que vous venez de nous décrire
tes sur la russie un peu sombre ce que
je voulais voir moi ce qui m'intéressait
de montrer dans le film c'est sûrement
pas la figure de staline si on veut
connaître ce qui est sa ligne à toutes
les archives du monde et tous les livres
du monde
moi je pensais que staline faisait
partie de la mémoire collective c'est à
dire eux la terreur des années de 30
dans la guerre de 40 et puis ensuite
donc je voulais montrer ce que devient
quelqu'un devant la peur je voulais
faire comme une fable que qu'est-ce
qu'on devient quand on a peur en quoi on
reste soi même qu'est ce qu'on perd de
soi même qu'est-ce que en quoi on va
vendre son âme ou pas donc c'est pour ça
que j'avais pris comme figures phares
staline quand vous parlez de la russie
avec gérard depardieu votre ami est-ce
que vous parlez de la même réussite ou
les deux oui finalement oui grosso modo
on se dispute parce qu'on n'est pas
toujours d'accord mais il a le même élan
que moi c'était lent ou par exemple
d'aller vers quelque fois les sentiments
extrêmes les colères ou où les larmes la
joie ou la danse voix ya quelque chose
on n'est pas on n'est pas pareil gérard
et moi mais on comprend les mêmes choses
et qu est ce que vous comprenez de la
gouvernance actuelle delà de la russie
vous savez bien ce qu'on en dit sur
paris l'a dit mir poutine c'est
compliqué c'est difficile est-ce que
c'est supportable caisse comment vous
réagissez à ça moi je pense toujours que
il y a dans la presse occidentale une
grande arrogance comme si la presse
occidentale
toujours dans le jugement donné les bons
points ou des mauvais points donc c'est
c'est je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui
regarde la télévision ou qu'il y
beaucoup les journaux
donc je sais qu'il y à cette strate 6
mhz et qu' il ya beaucoup de choses à
critiquer dans la rue si beaucoup comme
il y avait beaucoup de choses à
critiquer dans la l'amérique
ce qui n'empêchait pas la france d'être
comme un valet de l'amérique
donc il ya toujours ce côté d'essayer de
changer le monde espérait toujours qu'il
y ait plus de liberté plus de solidarité
mais qu'il faut pas non plus être naïf
donc c'est vrai que moi quand je parle
de la russie je ne parle pas du
gouvernement
je parle des êtres humains
je parle des russes vous y allez souvent
russie 1 fanny ardant oui de temps en
temps oui finalement assez souvent et la
dernière fois que j'ai c'est aller
j'étais invité par ce grand acteur
vladimir mashkov
qui a pris la direction d'un théâtre
magnifique et il m'a invité pour jouer
une pièce que j'avais joué à paris qui
était la pièce de marguerite duras
hiroshima mon amour et c'était
magnifique de pouvoir présenter un soir
aux moscovites hiroshima mon amour je me
rappelle de choses très intéressant
parce qu'elle est grand traducteur
tu vois des l'intelligentzia des gens
très fin très et je sais que on a
consulté aperçu que dans le russe
il n'y avait pas de futur antérieur
parce que dans hiroshima mon amour allié
à un moment tu meures à vue et les
discutions à perte de nuit pour savoir
comment on va traduire ça fanny ardant
quand on avance dans la vie on a la foi
des souvenirs et vous en avez fait
partager à beaucoup puisque ce sont vos
films vous avez des regrets
parfois vous avez des regrets de ne pas
avoir travaillé avec tel ou tel
réalisateur ou es ce que vous avez
encore le projet de vous dire peut-être
j'aurai la chance de travailler avec
celui ci ou celui là ça moi ce que
j'aime dans ce métier c'est que une
minute avant savait rien ça peut être un
coup de téléphone où ça peut être dans
la boîte aux lettres un scénario où
quelqu'un donc moi j'aime l'idée que
voilà on marche dans la savane et que
tout d'un coup il ya une liane qui passe
et on l'apprend je n'aime pas l'idée de
programmer les choses
je n'ai jamais écrit à un metteur en
scène pour eux tourner avec lui c'est
comme une histoire d'amour ne faut pas
supplier donc là vous n'avez pas de
message à envoyer à un metteur en scène
en particulier ou un réalisateur y est
je voudrais terminer surgir un point qui
équipe qui m'a toujours intéressé chez
vous c'est votre voix tout le monde a dû
vous en parlez vous avez une voix
particulière vous avez une tonalité un
timbre de voix
vous auriez sans doute pu faire beaucoup
de radios vous auriez pu faire du chant
vous avez chanté une ou deux fois 1
avec amoureuse on a dû vous proposé de
chanter on m'avait proposé de faire des
disques mais moi je suis comme tout le
monde c'est à dire que j'aime chanter
quand vous prenez votre bain ou caen
vous marchez dans la rue ou dans la
forêt mais j'estime que d'être chanteurs
et chanteuses c'est un vrai métier
c'est quelque chose qu'on travaille on
peut pas s'improviser chanteur donc
chanté dans un film ou faire un duo avec
une chanteuse ou un chanteur que vous
adorez c'est comme un un sorte de clin
d'oeil parce que j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup la chanson donc je les écoute
énormément donc mais je ne serai jamais
disque le duo vous aviez fait avec
véronique sanson choix elle voulait
faire tout un disque c'est plus je suis
pas sûr de ça mais j'aime beaucoup aussi
alex beaupain avec qui j'ai chanté je me
rappelle l'avoir chantée avec julien
clerc
c'est comme si c'était en douce entre
deux portes comme si bon c'est pas très
sérieux mais c'est bien sauf qu'il ya
aussi un petit chanteur un petit
chanteur qui est maintenant avec un prix
de la caf est une chanson sur vous il ya
du cac tourne énormément 1 en france
vous le savez ça fait quel effet ça
d'avoir une chanson sur soi assez commun
c'est une déclaration d'amour
oui c'est magnifique fanny ardant merci
beaucoup merci mille fois pour cette
conversation
finalement cette émission est terminée
mais vous la retrouvez bien sûr en
rediffusion sur l'antenne sur tous les
réseaux sociaux et puis sur le site
internet
rt france tv merci encore mme fanny
ardant a très vite
[Musique]